bella a tutti i ragazzi e per minuti
questo video sono poi ci siamo dati su
da un plesso oggi siamo con pietro e con
giampiero che si è unito al gruppo
eccoli allora ragazzi blues band
volevo quindi ringraziare towneplace per
aver personalizzato anche questo video
adesso hanno fatto un aggiornamento
incredibile andiamo a vedere anche cosa
hanno aggiunto tra l 1 ed è prima dico
agi cli screen fermano somigliano aiuto
per professione un secondo prima di
partire ragazzi questo mondo fantastico
volevo ricordarvi che potete utilizzare
il codice creator fa vigenti v che
appare in sovraimpressione perché
giampiero l'ha messo bravo gianpi
utilizzate con il suo fotografare anche
su dow place supportato neanche lì il
gioco lo trovate in descrizione come
trovate anche i miei amici invece noi
non li trova descrizione miei amici non
li trovo proprio dove siete
tra l'altro ragazze che hanno dato un
sacco di roba quindi posso sciupare
subiamo all'inizio del video choc
allora visto che ho sciupato perché io
shop.org la metà mazzotti nieri compensa
io cosa mi han dato stavolta
ricordo del corsaro ma ha detto che so
cool nudo veramente un attimo tanto nel
negozio se avesse avesse dei soldi che
non avete deve essere lingotto dei
platini che non avete cosa comprendesse
sicuramente un e volte sfiga tipo e
molto atterraggio è la processione armi
sono proprio belle
eh si si si sta guardando proprio le
aree una lancia no
raga fermi guarda scritta ragazzi fermi
tutti mentre stavo sciupando scoperta
sta roba
ce l'ho anch'io locali china grazie
prego cia ovviamente ragazzi penso anche
la licenza di caccia ad alti livelli con
piacere perché io show
andiamo avanti col viso ragazza eccoci
qua
ma cos'è ma risveglio è pronto come sei
perché l'erba sei bellissimi uno occhio
una sfilata di moda sembra questo è
bellissimo prima
grazie mille ma ecco guarda com'è ora
con l'elmo va bene guardiamo ragazzi sto
gioco si fanno i cubetti ai mostri
praticamente lo stesso era capito però
ve lo dico io
tra l'altro mi sa che devo sposare un
attimo la webcam perché li vado a
coprire il nome dell'agente spettatori
posizionata sotto perché almeno sei
schiacciate si vede buongiorno
ok diano a cercare per una volta ho
trovato prima io si parla d'altro lato
si parte bene io ti odio menate alle
gambe come su un chip insomma va bene da
chi si arriva all ardenza volevo fare il
paio di cagate in partenza se
completamente solo grazie allora vediamo
di menarlo meno almeno lo sulla taglia è
arrivato quanto è andato giù quasi
complimenti ragazzi sia squadra farà un
successo incredibile partiamo va bene
sembriamo aldo giovanni e giacomo che ha
lucertola il cavaliere però bloccati la
carica
non è colpa il mio però l'effetto sono
finito tutte le pozioni ma per il resto
a posto madonna laganà assurdo adesso
fare niente rops porto e dai la partenza
funziona allora io ho capito che tu hai
voglia d'estate di vendere il sole per
ora due sì non è un po troppo devo dire
che c'è
hai un mostro gigantesco dietro un altro
varco leroy e le major mente di questa
mappa si e milano adesso eccoci qua
massimo pericolo il rap perché non posso
darvi perché facciamo schifo ho le gambe
già possono comprare nel pas battaglia
anche la bravura questo sono morto
pietro aiuto grazie grazie
ma di degrado aspetti grazie prego no ti
devi togliere e sono porta basta alexa
metti il the sound of silence di simon e
garfunkel dopo che hai distrutto la coda
da seduto sono stato via bra grazie
bravissimi resi così non posso esserne
anche qui nasce la coda fuori e ucciso
bravi ragazzi poi io vi sto scusando non
so tu ma il core angolo ora c'è una
faccia di albano pochi ragazzi ho
trovato il nemico amico che possiamo
affrontare cielo questo nemico che fa
per noi
signorina lei di fortuna buongiorno cose
che puoi fare ti permette di affrontare
dei ben più potenti però questo qua solo
nel caso foste forti noi non abbiamo
signori eccomi allora pronti ci siamo
qua oppure tu rosa sono sailor moon
amico mio
eccolo ma ecco pietro pietro vertova
mano ci siamo
aiuto amico questo le brave ragazze
stavolta qual è il nostro è morto
no non regge e bastos finito due secondi
preparatevi a premere troppo così
ritorna in basso si sente così bravi ai
a chiamare uno detto vai e vai
anticamente la cantina ti spacchiamo
qualche cosa che con la coda
no no è bravissima nonna mia è morto non
è morto è morto è morto mentre cadevo
sailor moon ei suoi amici ce l'hanno
fatta lauren guardati un posto come
l'antica di girati da un tetto all'altro
perché no no no no no no ovviamente no
guarda mai così ma l'intero quindi
ragazzi in questo gioco aspetto quindi
ragazzi questo gioco di quei ragazzi
questo gioco molto serio o remo vedere
quanto valiamo gruppo trovato che non lo
vedo neanche un lama don't in pelle
buongiorno madonna mia si carica
scherzavo di successo ma è paura
ragazzini non posso giocare a questo
gioco se che succede la nuova thema è
bellissimo merito e ville e geniale
mamma mia mamma ma veramente bene questo
la cava elevato sacco e un cornuto e
mazziato
o mio dio no vabbè fermi cioè i no
ragazzi io gli sono andato in bocca fare
complimenti non lo sono perché forse
dovrei curarmi un attimino perché sono
stato io come non detto
incredibile voluto restare qua perché
mia mamma gemma queste fai lì ci sono
scusate ma non ti piacciono
no non mi piacciono o mio dio e non pil
armor rompula armored no questo colpo
enorme più più devo spaccare sta roba da
roma che vanta bravissimo sei rotto
qualcosa o svolgere rotto il ca pietro
aia chiama le scappa esplosione moglie
spaccato un qualcosa
ok a posto e scappato via foto perché
voglio poi andando non ha gli chiedono
che a tutti di gesù grande gianpi lori
lauren ore a roma come è stata scusa sì
io sto seguendo terra
la cosa più sbagliata il mondo esatto
però ragione eccolo infatti ecco
credente ho trovato l'ho trovato equa
madonna mi soddisfo nothing faccia
fortissimo campi ma quale 8 e non prendi
solo di notte lo so il giardino si
riposa non sono una da e sonno e quindi
non si sono risparmiati circa carte
facciamo questo qua è morto non potevi
si è morto lo guarda morto morto
no ragazzi sta andando stai significato
nel microonde e new city però che caldo
che non muore e non muore
tutti noi ma è un ora che lo pio che ho
già fatto che danno io che insomma ha
fatto prima
no ragazzi purtroppo sempre a terra già
di ottime line compagni giusti in questo
quest'oggi e vabbè allora è comunque
forte c'è un sacco di roma ragazzi
dobbiamo buttato giù sì sì sì e tre ore
ora cavalcano il successo ha fatto un
urlo eh sì mi sono visto la morte in
faccia per la sedicesima volta tanto per
cambiare oggi che ma sta lanciando i
casini como ragazzi ma ora il suo gioco
o no ecco io ok non incastrato
toglietevi per favore ragazzi prego un
giorno bongio allora io mentre riprendo
lui sì allora volevo fare considerazioni
ringrazio pietro per essere sempre così
gentile nel farci vincere le partite
senza di lui non sarebbe stato non
saremmo stati in grado di farlo
ringrazio giampiero per essere morto
nelle prime due e io e tutto video che
vi sia piaciuto come si vive il momento
mi piace vi ricordo che pensa volete
scaricare towneplace trovate i link in
descrizione in questo video riportatemi
con il pollice creator e noi come sempre
ci vediamo non fossimo malmena mento di
creature è mossa però vi faccio vedere
cosa che merita che stanno facendo sti
due spie spiegatemi giampiccolo davanti
cosa state facendo esattamente va bene
bella ragazza
[Musica]
ma